i do
show us the tips yo that's all good
that's good really all right [ __ ]
all right cool
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot boxing
i'm evan britton and i'm mike tyson
great voice man thanks brother i'm
working on it just having fun with it
you know so we don't do the same thing
every time
hey man we've got omarion in the house
brother hey hey
how are you man brother how are you and
your brother
orion orion yes great names
you guys thanks to mom's mom
that's cool i i definitely vibe with
that man
yeah well take us back brother you've
you've had a really
successful career in music and
transitioning into the acting world as
well
and tell us about you know growing up
you you're born in englewood right down
the street yeah la native
you still have family down there yep
still have family all my family is here
you know uh los angeles is a a very
unique place
especially you know um just as far as
you know cultural you know goes um i've
never seen anything like
it before yes it's amazing place and
shout out to my nana
you know that that kept you know me and
my brother
well culture a lot of people don't know
but at a very young age um i was a
professional rollerblader
really yeah right how [ __ ] was that
how old you hurt yourself a lot no i
know i was one of those kids that's like
you know i just
i didn't really have fear like that so
you know i put on a
a pair of roller blades and we used to
go to santa rosa there should be this
camp called cam snoopy
and um we would go out there every year
and we would just like
santa rosa up north yeah
mike i [ __ ] was playing roller hockey
rollerblading around brooklyn from the
time i was about eight years old
until probably until i got to high
school and started playing football
yeah yeah dude yeah so you know this is
a special place to me
you know um my mom is actually a hair
stylist
and um before i was entertaining i went
to hamilton high it's
actually a lot of alumni come out of
hamilton high tell me about it yes so
shia labeouf went to hamilton
um robert richard went to hamilton it's
a
magnet program um but it's like a
like a creative schools few few schools
in
california like where other successful
people came out of
like well i am went to palisades you
know um
anyone that's from california like you
know this part of l.a
she usually go to the same school you
know what i'm saying so how do you guys
hang out so what do you do you see your
school used to play hit school in sports
well uh who who you talking about well i
am oh no oh well yeah
uh hamilton plays you know karen shaw
that's
you know a lot of a lot of players came
from chris yeah
dorsey oh yeah dorsey
dorsey man i had a lot of teammates come
out of dorsey
yeah doris d house yeah d house yeah so
great football program yeah so um you
know
la you know hollywood all of this these
are these are our stomping rounds this
is where we're
born and bred and created from you know
what i'm saying interesting place to be
from
yeah it is very interesting yeah it
could be good or bad
yeah absolutely you want to get a nice
mix though
[Laughter]
a mix of good and bad yeah what's what's
the good and the bad
i'm scared of bad tell us the good and
the bad of l.a growing up [ __ ] scared
of bad anything
bad i'm scared yeah anything [ __ ] bad
well the gang culture here was uh very
prevalent you know and
a lot of people you know um
well being young and kind of having it
in my in my
household you know because it was a very
uh
it was normal to us you know um my dad
was in y.a at 15.
you know um and my mom had me at 16. so
it was like really like
younger than young guys yeah
yeah yeah so wow that's hardcore living
huh yeah yeah
yeah so you know um
you know uh being here
wait a minute i forgot where we were 15
16 mother father
yes um
thank you let's edit that out the weed
is too good all right
we got you bro make you look bad you
look bad we look good okay
but um yeah like i was saying gang
culture is very prevalent in la
so you know um kids having kids
you know um you do the best that you can
you know what i'm saying
no [ __ ] um [ __ ] book on how to do
that [ __ ]
ain't no blueprint yes no blueprint you
just gotta go
yeah so you know luckily we we have some
you know my grandma my nana shout out to
my nana
yeah nat shout out to grandma nana
nana we love you my mother-in-law two
and father-in-law they're the best in
the world
like that what's that white chick
hillary clinton said and listen she must
have learned that from some old wise
person it takes the village to raise the
child
yeah oh yeah you need everybody in the
[ __ ] family to help out
no doubt even if you got to break them
off but you need the family this
it's going to go [ __ ] up yes
i got experience is going to go real bad
it's so true
yeah it takes a village yeah so
so with them being so young you know
gang culture was like
pretty normal here you know what i'm
saying so we grew up with
with pretty much people that we just
seen
stand up for ourselves and that's why we
wanted to be like
them the gang guy is now pretty friendly
kind of guy
no it's different it's definitely now
you know what i mean people know they
are everybody every police station know
who they are
you know i mean no one knows they have
no privacy right
you know really yeah yeah yeah it's not
it's not the same when we were growing
up
all of uh who we considered our big
homies was like
you know they had things you know they
had money you know they dressed well
even though it was like in you know
khaki suits and
they feel good and they had the best
looking girl yeah that's really good
they got the guy
yeah that that was the swag so growing
up here in california you know
definitely a part of some clicks some
different little games my best friend
actually shout out to um bd
you know he has life in prison actually
big b
you know i'm saying that's that's my boy
right there but i always look at our
relationship we
literally started our friendship um in
kindergarten
and uh you know he's a mexican brother
and um
you know life was just so different from
him as far as the opportunities
you know and it was just so interesting
throughout my life that
even still to this day when i talk to
him you know it's like he's a different
person
he's so um his his perspective of life
he's always telling me you know like hey
oh don't worry about that man you know
uh where you might want to think twice
about that oh because you don't want to
be anywhere
look at this perspective why do you
think that
even then you're out here i think it was
just just
choice just opportunity and choice and
perspective
yeah yeah because you know
that was available for i mean you know
we hung out all the time that was
available for me too
but i think because you know my mom had
us
you know focusing maybe on other things
or maybe that
space wasn't so so available for us
you know that um i was able to choose
something different
like yeah everyone everyone's path is
different
you know and it's like you know i think
we could talk about
you know what what could be done
differently but when you really look at
it and you experience you're like man i
needed to go through that in order to
receive that information so i think it's
just so
interesting that the even though we grew
up in the same space
you know our our information in our past
was just really completely different
i think that's an important thing you
know about having the
you can only do the best possible thing
for yourself with the information you
have at the time
right you know right and that's just one
of those
inevitable things of life because you
can hear it
you know as kids like you hear a lot of
[ __ ] as a kid from older people
telling you things about how life is and
how it's going to be
and a lot of it just goes in one ear and
out the other because you're like [ __ ]
that
that's not me bro i won't deal with that
listen but it takes that experience then
why is it this way
why does god program us to look for
answers that we know we never find in
our lifetime
[Music]
hmm
i think you um both you know i think
that you can
like like you were just saying about bd
you know you can go through and the
differences between one guy and another
and one guy having one path and another
guy taking another one
you know it's about you can only get
those answers through the experience you
have
because you think that that's the best
way to do it at the time
and then you go down that path and you
go oh [ __ ] well this led to
prison or whatever it might have led to
divorce something bad happening in your
family
you know the consequences of your
actions
um and you can only learn that through
experience the concept of that
through getting your ass kicked yeah i
guess so yeah yeah that's
that's really important you know all
that you know life yeah through just
getting your ass kicked and getting up
again
you know right i mean mike you talked
about it before the um
you know you try a hundred times you
fail a hundred times you learn a hundred
lessons
exactly you know and with
it's really because you know if we're on
this ride with the universe
we're just riding this cosmic wave all
of us
you know and you can only do the best
you can with what you have
then it's really just up to us to get
out of our way stuff now i gotta come
back to this stuff
you know you said that right now i get
mad sometimes sometimes i'm disgusting
from
depressed no mine yeah i said why do i
exist why do i exist to feel pain like
this
why did god make me exist so i could
feel pain i did nothing wrong with
anybody
why do i have to exist yeah
at least i don't think i did anything
wrong my consciousness don't know but
if i really did anything wrong to exist
yeah it's my purpose
to beat [ __ ] up to get in this
wee business and make a lot of money
though
what is it to do to meet people to meet
you to talk to you
yeah to help me in my journey to figure
out who i am
i don't know what is this all about why
do i have to just why do i have to die
[ __ ] right why would that go
why would that be oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
maybe you don't
yeah i wake up when i think i do that i
wake up oh [ __ ]
into the next life and i think
i don't know man like why does anything
have to exist
why does anything exist it's all
expressions of life
well well from my perspective if i could
candidly speak on
you know how you've inspired people
and you've inspired you know me
particularly just as far as
you know the will to not give up in a
fight
because um you know unlike a lot of
uh i guess people don't really know
um when you're when you're fine-tuning
and refining your skills how much time
you actually
spend doing just that and how that
really becomes
a comfort and almost a
separate identity from how people
know you outside of that and you have
such a high skill set
um that you know i just connect with
that
i i i watched you on um
recently online and you had a blindfold
and you were
throwing the dart and something
something unique that i saw
when uh when when i was watching that
was
your ability to hear the sound and
figure out
where your target was without seeing it
and
that just takes a lot of time that's so
interesting that you said that
and um that was one of those moments
that's one of your zen moments where um
i had no idea it was i had no idea what
was going to happen
but i just knew it was going to be good
i said i said what did i say
because you hit three bull's eyes i said
shaolin monk i said this is going to be
some shaolin monk [ __ ] what and it's
once
they put the nice new the first one was
no the first one i
thought i practiced the first one and it
was there i missed the board
okay and i missed the [ __ ] boy
and then they blindfolded me i had three
three bows what the [ __ ] happened now
how does that happen
no i i did a practice shot without the
[ __ ] dads and i missed the board i'm
gonna go
without the math and i missed the board
i said [ __ ]
that yo but i really i really connected
with that and i could tell that
that's just that's just next level you
know you spent a lot of time
you know in your field you know what i
mean being the best
yeah and i feel like you know that's
what that's what life is about
reaching your highest potential yeah
yeah and it it
echoes on both sides because now you are
doing the weed business that's a part of
healing
that's a part of healing look at like
the first half of
your life and then you know you fought
most of your life and now
you're healing you know what i mean and
i feel like it's like that it's
beautiful
with that one that's really true i like
that one that's well said bro
that was some thin [ __ ] right yeah
i'm in other words plugged in dude
right in other words i'm repenting all
the people i heard or whatever and
i heard even myself i hurt myself right
right and repenting
yeah because i definitely want to come
to the facility oh that's oh you're
you're there you know what i'm saying
yeah and uh me and my brother
we uh just a couple of days ago i had
our uh first experience with aya
tell me about ayahuasca oh that's why
you're all tapped in
[Laughter]
oh i got you someone
[Music]
well so you know about do you know about
the toad
oh that was going to be our next
experience
the campbell right uh that's combo
combo is is another frog that's the
green or the skinny frog it's a big it's
a big frog in the amazon oh it's a
skinny frog
and this this produces i've done combo
in ayahuasca but what i'm talking about
is the toad
bufo alvarius which is five meow dmt
so ayahuasca is dmt
so if ayahuasca is like the riverboat
because you're there all night
you're in it right the riverboat to god
the toad is the spaceship to god so it's
a 15 minute
15 minutes blast off you go
ego death experience god
download thousands of years of
information
and minutes you know are released from
trauma and pain
mike has done it a few times now how was
it um
can't even explain you're gonna have to
do is i'm inconceivable
you can't believe it you won't believe
it wow
you have to do it again you say let me
do it again even though you're afraid to
death to do it again you have to lose it
the [ __ ] is not real i have to see this
whoa combo's great as a prep to the toad
as well
okay you don't really need a prep mike
just went in
mike went in hard to the toad i would
have got a prep writer
if i was just gonna stay if i thought i
might do it on the
i would never have done it i would never
have done that i was just high and i
said
give me the [ __ ] [ __ ] and he gave it
to me and that happened my whole life
has been changed i've never been the
same way
yeah i never got high again they cocaine
no hair i never did no more drugs again
and stuff
never drank again right no it's my whole
perspective
tell us about tell us about your
ayahuasca yeah did you [ __ ] on yourself
nah no yeah i didn't have any of that
either yeah no i threw up after we did
hoppe
you do the hoppe where they blow the ash
in your nose
oh that look sounds good to me that's
some good [ __ ]
that sounds good oh that's some good
[ __ ] i like stuff
so hop a is this is this uh ash
that's from all these amazonian herbs
and a special kind of tobacco
oh okay and it's burned down to an ash
and then they put it in an animal horn
i thought they did that blow it up your
nose
yeah what did that i thought that was a
form of cocaine i thought that's the way
they did cocaine back um
yeah i mean it's different it's i saw
that in the movie in the victorian day
the 1890s
yeah it's just clears out
your whole nervous system it's [ __ ]
you feel like
fireworks in each hemisphere of your
brain opens [ __ ] up
it's supposed to clear out energy
blockages and like
you know your different energy fields um
and you do that before and and during
ayahuasca so i was doing that and that
took me to the [ __ ] next level
when i was on the aisle so tell us about
it
man it was amazing it's amazing it was
amazing first of all
um i i didn't really know what to expect
but um i was comfortable with
uh letting myself go oh
yeah yeah so the the information that i
got from
from aya was basically that um
life is just life is a dance and we just
have to keep dancing i love that
and that's that's what i received you
know what i mean and i was just like
really happy
with um where i'm at my life and
you know um i have two kids you know
what i'm saying so i have a good
piece of motivation right there i have
um
just i'm really optimistic about what's
going on
if you did the toads right everybody
around what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
they will all see your glow they would
say what the [ __ ] wrong they couldn't
get away from you
yeah listen you wouldn't want to be here
it'll be
it's be so it's so enlightening [ __ ]
[ __ ] listen but your whole life would
change no
that's why i'm all about that yeah never
been
listen i came here i was i don't know
what i was i came i did the toad
and i did it again and it told me to get
in condition i must have
lost 50 pounds whoa yeah
listen i always use god for some kind of
[ __ ] relationship for a purpose to
use thing and get my interest
i really understood it was a god there
is god [ __ ]
and you don't see him you feel it's all
about feeling doing the toes about
feeling you don't see
you you might listen you might you might
just start crying you might be so
and it ain't nothing there you just feel
afraid right
i had nothing i couldn't fight nothing
nothing i was afraid
wow then you come after you beat the
happiest moment in your life
then you get back in life you wake up in
this downer the worlds are down and you
want to go back
i woke up i was so afraid but when i
woke up
oh god i don't want to be here no my
wife took another head and give me some
more
oh they're down and when you wake up you
don't want to be here no more
damn yeah
because you reach that state of bliss
yeah you felt that feeling your ain't
gonna feel that good
oh so everything you ever did in your
life your first kiss your first drink of
water your first joint
that's heavy candy your first third your
first outbreak ready your first [ __ ]
your first piss off phillips i want
rocks the bugs [ __ ] grass all of it is
us yeah the metallics in the grass and
the ground
all that stuff the minerals where all
that life
man that's powerful yeah it's powerful
yeah that's
with everything that's cool that you're
on that journey dude
yeah man it feels appropriate you know
thanks to my brother
listen right if we finish this life and
we die
and we don't get to know this we have a
wasted life
yeah yeah it was wasted you don't get to
know us
yeah it's wasted and mike wouldn't you
say that's uh
you know because when you say that
in conjunction with a conversation about
these powerful molecules chemicals
because these substances that's what
they're all about
is learning about the truth of what's in
yeah listen you find
you start asking yourself why do i do
this [ __ ] right do i want people to
listen to me do i want people to look at
me do i feel
beautiful when they do that why do i do
that do i love myself that much
am i in love with the illusion of me why
do i do that you never talk to that in
the [ __ ] mic but do yourself
you start wondering who the [ __ ] am i
who the [ __ ] am i i'm nobody who the
[ __ ] am i that thinks
you bow to me i yelled my name on the
plot you might get mad at yourself
yeah who am i who the [ __ ] am i these
guys love me and stuff
do they know who i really am do they
know what i did to cheated on my
girlfriend or something like that
yeah they didn't know those qualities i
possessed and they still wanted me to be
around them
right you finally feel why do i do that
now you try to figure out who you are
what the
[ __ ] and this one right and our whole
life
we look for answers and we die knowing
nothing
but we don't stop looking to you until
this last second we're living we still
still [ __ ] searching you don't figure
out [ __ ] yeah see i
i feel i feel a good strong
sense of purpose and i think when you
when you have a sense of purpose you
know um you're able to just anchor
yourself a little bit better
what made you want to come back um
it was a lot of things mainly my kids
yeah i use
i use the energy of you know
the kid in me and my kids
to bring about you know maybe some
things that maybe i
you know couldn't do uh ten years ago
like
forgive uh
yeah try that you think forgiving
somebody else is hard
but but try forgiving yourself try that
no another level
that's the whole total number yeah i
mean but when you really when you really
like as you were saying
you know you're only able to do you know
what you know
so to speak when you really understand
how much you don't know that kind of
changes the game
yeah that changes the game because then
you know you want to learn more
and then when you get your grip on more
you know you got to ask yourself
why you want more you know and in order
to get to a certain level
you got to have purpose because if you
don't have purpose then you're going to
keep
asking yourself that question what's
your purpose yeah
i think my purpose is is this the
purpose
of of of everyone and that is
to share i think that we're all here to
share
and i think that if we share you know
that's a part of the dance as well
you know um a lot of people don't even
dance with women and actually that
message has been kind of
lost and i i really hope men understand
the importance of dancing
and having that conversation with a
woman because
i was a [ __ ] candidate i want
to dance so bad i can't fight
all right what do i do what do i do show
us the tips
all right [ __ ] all right cool there you
go okay
cause life is a rhythm okay you know
what i'm saying it's just like a punch
no that's cool i'm listening it's the
same thing oh [ __ ] nobody been
laughing my wife in the white men are
laughing dancing [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah i
totally vibe with that bro
i caught a couple of episodes when you
was on uh dance with the
that was dope my wife was mad that the
girl was trying to take my handkerchief
and white [ __ ]
she wanted to fight the italian girl and
stuff
but yeah like so so what what the
my point is is that and and you know
shout out this [ __ ] give him a [ __ ]
show i can tell
a [ __ ] love black love extraordinaire
black love dude but that's good man
good stuff me and my brother we were
just in uh new york
and uh shout out to the 36 chambers we
went out there and
all those guys out there no actually no
no it's actually 36 chambers is
this um back in the day yeah for sure
36 chambers of style but it's dance
[ __ ] no salute to the gods salute to
gods but
36 chambers of style if of of
it's it's actually a dance camp that um
you know a lot of just legendary
dance you know artists through the ages
they put on together and it's 36
different styles
so when you go to the class you learn
you know about partnership you learn
about
you know where a lot of moves originated
and me and my bro we just
went like a month ago and the whole
conversation
was like we had a partner day and
throughout the partner day you just
switch partners all day and that's like
the whole purpose of dancing
is to share and if if everyone could
really understand
that that's what life is about it's
sharing i think
we will have a better okay cool let's
listen
all right pick this out let me go
my wife yeah her assistant
baby share it with me right
she assists you she should assist me
later right
that's cool right yeah why would she be
mad
i don't know we talking about ladies
yeah we're
talking about that we talk about women
that's that's different
yeah it's a complex thing yeah why
because you're saying they're sharing
and listen
and some and some coaches that's good
but why not in this coach
who said um who said this before someone
said this
we should only have one mate who said
that what queen now
what queen got that guy i got the king
[ __ ] whip that he said hey this is how
it's going to be well that happened some
queen got somebody [ __ ] whip and he was
powerful
and that's what happened that's what
happened yeah well common sense you know
that's what happened or his mother
it had the men and women's figure most
of the strongest powerful
um warriors in the world were all [ __ ]
but from their mother they're afraid of
their mothers and [ __ ]
alexander the great napoleon that my
mother
i don't know where that culture that's
interesting
i don't know where that culture comes
from you know what i'm saying i don't
know where that originated
but i do agree with you and i'm not
saying we should have more than one wife
you know somebody but like where did
that concept come from who created that
concept that only one would do
and says in the quran you could have
four bones if you knew anyone would do
yeah that's who would want to have that
concept nobody nobody rational would
want to have that concept
they may not say so now because people
may look at it but the rational guys say
that doesn't make sense only one person
and one
but why who made sense out of that who
made sense out of that
i mean go ahead man i i think
i think that their thoughts on it i
think that there's
um different perspectives and i think
sometimes
maybe if you know someone looked at
someone being in love and maybe with one
person that they would assume that that
is the way to be
and it kind of echoes this sentiment
that maybe at some point in time it only
took one woman maybe it did
and you know maybe it takes several
women
maybe it's different for you maybe it's
different for me yeah you know
maybe it's all different as men
in our brain we're wired to spread our
seed
to get ourselves to reproduce as much as
possible to
pro-generate to create you know more
versions of us
we're actually wired for that
so which is a very real instinct in men
you know and it's very difficult to
overcome but i don't
but listen we might be why we're wired
for that feeling of becoming
yes because i don't feel good having a
bunch of kids all over the place
no you don't you don't feel good you
don't feel good about it you feel good
doing that
i agree and i think that you don't feel
good either with a bunch of meaningless
partners
exactly you know so you know to me
meaningless partners destroyed me oh
like my life
destroyed my [ __ ] life yes brought me
down these brothers brought me to my
[ __ ] bad me begging off
[ __ ] baby kill me more so then mike
it's so good yay
because that's real that's real so then
ask yourself
i mean i should have never been [ __ ]
with no [ __ ] so then
numb on me these women got me
good man doesn't it become then that you
would rather have
one but partner
if you knew one would do yeah back then
four headaches
imagine them all living in the same
house but imagine all of them
loving you and giving you that other
level [ __ ] but i'm just saying
but i'm just saying i'm just saying
what a song and maybe that would be real
for a moment
but eventually things would happen when
i was younger and then i had a bunch of
girls in the same room as they hit them
all the time do all the stuff and then
they come
and if this happens that you like one of
them more than you like the next one
how did that happen not the [ __ ] and
one of them
one of them probably thinks that you are
theirs
more than the others yeah but but see no
because i think that's the wrong focus
that's the wrong focus because it's not
natural
yeah it's very natural but you know
that's
i would say i would say you have one of
one
all your relationships if you really
individualize all this would be one that
we like more than another
but not even that it's not about liking
one more than the other it's about what
we have
it doesn't matter what i have with her
because you don't understand that
you don't know that what me and her have
is what we have
and that's what that is and then when me
you have what we have no this is all
separate
that's good that's beautiful but this is
how i feel right now this is our program
now
all right this is my wife it ain't no
more [ __ ] i'm not the [ __ ] freak
no more
right i don't want to be that person who
might want to be dedicating my life to
this [ __ ] woman right here
yeah so how did that how did i become
the [ __ ] anybody could have me guide
to this
well you felt all the pain dude yeah and
there's no doubt you don't feel that's
[ __ ] a billion [ __ ] or something a
lot of [ __ ] you still feel like
these i thought i was thinking some of
these [ __ ] is taking away so much
from me
yeah i feel like [ __ ] i don't feel good
no more
every time i'm in a room i see somebody
they have a family and i might have been
with them
but they're happy and i'm miserable yeah
you know what i mean
i should be saying hey i busted it but i
feel like [ __ ]
i feel like they walked all over me i
feel like they all took pieces from me
right it's like a [ __ ]
yeah it is it's interesting it is i i
really i don't have them
the idea of all this [ __ ] was to possess
them i don't possess them just whoever
got them in the table where they possess
them what do they know
it's just that and then even that it's
like possessing somebody that's
momentary
right like no it is yeah my wife looked
at me the other day and said wow
one day this is going to be over i'm not
going to be able to see you anymore
[Music]
that's crazy man and that could be true
and that could be a lie because
because to me but not even that you know
to me it's like i stain you i stain you
i'm a part of your story now you can't
go nowhere
so tell me this yeah you must have a
harem so you you haven't
no i don't know i know no no no no no i
don't know
yeah i stand because you only have one
person that you're staying there how
many four people use
no i i actually you may do a lot of
staining you painting
you're painting a lot of pictures no no
actually i think that
you know you can really truly the
universe cultivates
how you know someone you know interacts
with you
and in your life and in your journey why
do you think why do you think that we
have to have
and actually so much interaction with
women so consistently
because most animals only [ __ ] a
certain season
right they see him out of season they're
fighting to the death yeah
i mean so why do you think that's a good
question so why do you think we need to
have so many
in such an awful situation i don't i
don't
see a guy i don't consistency of it
right i don't know that
it's about i mean don't get me wrong you
know
it's an aspect of creation there
it's an aspect of creating your new
version of yourself your new
you know um in every relationship
yeah yeah with every person yes and also
in sex
because sex is very powerful and a lot
of things
change in that space you know and when i
don't believe sex is as powerful as um
it's gotta
it's overrated i don't believe it's that
powerful i am a situation where women
are riding guys and they're getting
their [ __ ]
[ __ ] right but it's not but see it's
not a physical thing
it's not that energetic it has to be no
it's all it's awesome
it has to be chemistry first before
that's what i'm saying it's all
imaginations all the thoughts that mean
this girl's gonna be [ __ ] on the
thought of having sex
it's more exciting than actually doing
it yeah but but but when you understand
the power of a touch
when you understand the power of a touch
that changes the game
and when a woman understands the power
of a touch it can literally heal you
yeah well she understands it you don't
we don't understand
but that's but that's the point you have
to progress in that
you have to want to become whole with
that you have to want to become one with
that and when you become one with that
you basically create that drug you know
what i'm saying
yeah and you get a fix yeah so you gotta
submit to that you're saying
um in a way yeah okay in a way but you
know but in a way
but in a way you have to go against it
it's a balancing act
you know it's a dance you have to know
when to go and know when to leave
i don't know i think the less you [ __ ]
them the less problems they are
yeah yeah i guess so yeah i mean it's so
many different ways to look at it
you know there's so many different ways
to look at it um
you know i think it's the right way man
it's all of our experiences are
different
i've had it all have to be it don't have
to be um dignity and
respect yes always first always first
always first because it can't be taken
it has to be given
you know all right it has to be received
too you know what i'm saying
it's a it's a reciprocal it's a
reciprocal of it
after you get kids but before you have
kids you know into your mind
yeah for sure for sure for sure i
wouldn't think about none of this
yeah for sure i had kids i said yeah
girls
huh yeah i have a girlfriend so imagine
thinking about a girl meeting a
[ __ ] like you you're doing i
mean i always think my daughter made a
[ __ ] like me when i was doing my
[ __ ]
yeah yeah imagine probably would i
imagine that some guy like that came to
my house
for the [ __ ] like me right i would just
say like me
yeah yeah i think about that i think
about that my daughter is very young
but i always say you know
if if if i could remove
the the the experiences the the small
experiences that we all have to receive
in order to grow
if i could move all of that if we just
put me down to one molecule
i'm a good one so if my daughter did end
up liking someone like me
then i would be okay with it well make
us think we're good
um i like to think we're bad uh i think
i think you're actually
good and bad yeah you can but you have
to create the
effect that you want so in order to
create the effect that you want you have
to have intention
so your intentions have to be what
effect you want
well my intentions imagine my intention
is to kill a guy like him like this
yeah then you might die but then you
might die if you want if your intention
to kill him then you might die
and laterally you might die and live
yeah i don't i don't want to do that
it depends it depends on your
perspective i'm trying to live
i'm going to live i'm going to survive
i'm going to thrive i'm going to
continue to live
we'll be living for it we need that
potential again right we still have
potential
all right to to reach the potential and
to share
or share to share to share this
experience is about sharing
if you're not sharing then what are you
doing we're sharing right now
so we're doing our job yes we are then
that's what i feel
i like this theory it's not gonna go
over good with my wife i really like
that well hold on let me let me hold on
let me just say this
okay and we all do respect to all the
goddesses and queens because i'm single
right now so i can explore
you know what i what what i would like
to explore
you know what i'm saying um but uh
why are you single with all the smooth
moves you got well
your logistics
because because i think that it's it's
it's been a good time i've been looking
at [ __ ] the shows [ __ ] i know know
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
no honestly i'm such a focused person
i'm a very focused person
you know what i'm saying so um i try to
manage
you know i'm saying my appetite because
i'm so focused
that you know my appetite could get
crazy so i manage
i manage my i manage i try to manage
myself as best as i can and right now
it's really like my kids are about to
start school next week for the first
time
i'm getting into another bag of
parenthood
so i can't tolerate a new dimension in
life yeah i can't i can't
i can't really have the uh i don't have
the energy
and and i can't really uh give
um i can't repeat myself brother i can't
repeat it
we're on the same level right now yeah
it's just i'm done yeah
i was before it's over yeah yeah yeah i
can't repeat myself and i can't explain
you know if you could pick it up that
would be amazing you know what i'm
saying but it's a lot of things going on
and really that's all about the kids
that's all about my kids you know what
i'm saying to
really be able to create some better
opportunities for them so when it's time
for them to go on their journey and face
what they need to face that they have
just a little bit more information how
do you how do we become good parents
what's a [ __ ] good parent
i think it's your effort you know it's
your honest onus
effort it's like what do you give a [ __ ]
about whatever that is
as long as you support that and they're
there for that consistently
that's a good parent but a [ __ ] up
parent is obviously someone that does
nothing or or selfish or you know
they have their own things that they're
dealing with that kind of take
precedence
over stepping outside of yourself and
being able to decide something for
the collective that's a good answer what
i'm saying
parenting it's about the collective come
on we got to get them on these [ __ ]
talk tours man with tony robbins and
[ __ ]
i know dude oh mike i was getting a lot
of knowledge
so you know um my uh
uh the the other day someone said
um what did he say he said um
i'm about positivity what'd he say oh he
said
vicious posit vicious positivity
you know and uh when he said that that
really resonated with me because that's
that's what people need
yeah vicious positivity because [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up
because everything everything positive
we say it gets multiplied
20 times 100 times by negativity yeah so
we can't say positive [ __ ] enough it's
overwhelmed
right we still got to say something
we're getting our ass kicked with
negativity but we still got to take
we're not winning but we still got to
stay positive now that's some [ __ ]
right but
that's the game [ __ ] keep it going ah
nah it ain't keep it going it's like
okay we recognize that that's there
so let it be there and let us focus on
the positions
of nowhere and it ain't going nowhere
positive you are the more you does this
push up and let's
just wait to come out facts in different
ways you got to dance with it it's going
to
it's going to make you say dance with me
mother exactly yeah capoeira
the darkness is relentless so the light
has to be relentless
balance that's it that's it there will
always be
i don't have no bounds i just go full
positivity
that's it that's [ __ ] it how far
apart in age are you guys
two years two years okay hey i'll say
something bro
love and abundance y'all
for real the ladies love it you know
what i'm saying oh he's the melody
that's how the cult that happened you
got
all those guys that had to coax at all
the women they had like a harem they
always had them all those guys had herms
of women
yeah yeah we were raised by all women
you know we didn't really have a lot of
male influence you know
as much as maybe we would have won it
you know what i mean
um but women have taught us a lot
you know and we appreciate them and i
think that we we should appreciate each
other more you know what i'm saying and
i think that
the world would be a different place if
we could do that if we could have a
better company why do we have
interaction bad interactions with women
i'm not talking about this black i'm
talking about
in general why do we have different i
think because we don't understand them
you know what i'm saying we don't
understand
they don't understand this problem yeah
but but somebody got to make the first
you know why don't you think god is a
woman it probably is
all right what do you think i i always
think that maybe it's called the woman
she's
playing with maybe it's a homophobic how
could he be how do you do
because how could god be one gender have
more identity have more favor for one
gender
and not for the other how could that be
god as we perceive genderless
yeah because love is probably not a a
procreation you know what i'm saying
yeah it's not a sexual thing you know
it's probably something else
i don't know like definitely the
mother's touch like that's love to us
too you know what i'm saying so i think
the extension
uh uh and understanding of god is just
unfathomable
on this planet that's why i believe we
can't even fathom his position of love
yo i hate what oh whoa
but it's all a beautiful creation you
know and you got to learn how to that's
what that's when you take the toe you
can't even fathom the love and the
uh the bliss that you feel that's why
you say you have to go back
the life is a [ __ ] downer once you
take that [ __ ] yeah
ooh what the [ __ ] am i doing here yeah
what the [ __ ] is happening no i'm so
happy that i was able to
procreate for real like and i look at my
kids and because
that [ __ ] is beautiful to me and man
like that that definitely keep me going
you know what i'm saying
because uh you know the world is is not
i look at my kids and say what do they
want out of life
what are they going to get out of life
because of the life i gave them that
might hinder them
imagine my life i had nothing my mother
was a prostitute
if i had nothing i was [ __ ] [ __ ] i
was still
that was my that was my um those are my
best qualities that i came from those
um that kind of lifestyle they're kind
of living and stuff
yeah my kids you know they count no
maybe that's not bad they never remember
having a good life or anything but
i look at them i said wow this is how i
would have been this would have been my
family if i
if i had my parents this is how i would
have been i said i don't know
i don't know
somewhere yeah whoa thank god
well isn't it interesting how i have a
chance that means i did have a chance
you know i mean if i could do it in
that's so low
situations imagine i'll do good in
middle-class situation or high-end
situation but then again i go back to
this how come sometimes the poor man is
blessed and the [ __ ] rich man is
cursed
yeah man i don't know you know why
it's interesting guy falls out the bed
and died the other guy falls 10 stories
and legs
because of yeah the polarity yeah it's
the law of the universe
yeah some people have destiny i believe
people have destiny
i believe people are how do you die what
do you see before you die the god goes
like this
the universe goes you've seen enough
boom it's over
when i see this it's up well this is
enough for you it's an interesting
thought i've had that myself yeah you
don't need to see no more it's
inconceivable for you won't understand
you're out of your league now it's time
for you to get done enough
yeah yeah maybe somebody's 20 years old
or 25 and they say you've done enough
you inspired the person i needed
inspired right now
all right right how does that work you
know yeah i mean
yeah that's that's heavy because if it's
all
spirit and it's all god then you kind of
have to go there
you know we're all here and it's all
written already
and you're riding that wave and we're
all doing it together
why do some people go earlier than
others
you know yeah um it's
fun we have do what do we actually meet
do we actually meet the maker when we
die maybe you just go again
yeah you just go right again you get
born again you come through the portal
one more time
you know now do you imagine
i can't imagine this but i'm sure they
might be but i can't imagine it but
anything that you
think of could actually be true in this
world right
yeah is there anybody that really
actually ever thought about what's going
to happen when i die
or they just take it hey where i'm going
i'm going but i see it baby
you know really yeah do everybody come
to that stage and i said because i
haven't thought about when i was living
my life and i'm [ __ ] everything
drinking smoking everything sniffing
everything
having nothing but then you get 15 whoa
i'm not going to see another city most
likely
you know what's going to be of me when i
no longer exist anybody remember me
would anybody talk about me
of course yeah what you mean no no no
would anybody really know me what
enemies did
now they were what image did i put out
in the world for people
right did i just put violence out there
the baddest man i planned my ego out
there
that the true me ever been really known
do you feel like i don't know
sometimes i'm understanding what the
[ __ ] i'm talking running my [ __ ] who
wants to hit my [ __ ] mouth what the
[ __ ] i know
i got a ninth grade education how could
i know anything but still you want to
listen to what the [ __ ] i got to say so
i say that's what the [ __ ] they talking
about what do they see that i don't see
well you've had the realization that you
know nothing too yeah
you know i know nothing but my job on
this show is not to let the people know
i don't know nothing
but maybe it is mike
maybe it is bro you know
maybe if you acknowledge that then the
[ __ ] down the street who's
riddled with ego and all his ideas about
what the world is supposed to be maybe
he'll go oh
wait maybe i don't know anything so i
say to myself so i say listen we get
close we got close to a million
views guys right so i said myself what
do a million people when they hear me
say
i'm going to say the word [ __ ] a lot
probably anything you want you know
and i don't like the fact that i say
that word i try to stop say that but it
comes out so you just flows out my mouth
without me even thinking about it
you go deep now yeah you guys are deep
dudes though
yo tyson fam
you don't even understand that you're
effects fat
yeah why would that why would you think
that though
like i think about me i think well man
you might chill out because i came i
can't sometimes listen even in prison
because i've never said my child could
really you know you're not like normal
people
you got to chill out you're too
sensitive you think everybody's out to
get me i think everybody loves to give i
think everybody's going to make fun of
me about something
right i got so much insecurity you know
maybe no self-love either that's how
come i act out viciously
okay there we go you know you want some
more brother
so yeah that's a whole different process
you have to go to that process you have
to first start to love yourself
but i got fame before i knew what
self-love was right so
the animal pretty much [ __ ] up [ __ ]
up
[Laughter]
you couldn't know that yet oh yeah i
mean i
i don't i don't personally you know uh
know like the the the fine details you
know what i'm saying
of your story but from what i've been
able to observe from the outside in man
you
are like definitely as far as my part of
time
a lot of aspects it is [ __ ] so much
[ __ ] yo
first of all fam me being a kid you know
what i'm saying
watching you squabble on tv
with the style like the quickness like
you was moving
just yo fam you want to look at it like
that you was tapping in i was like yo
how's he moving like that
it's moving so [ __ ] fast yo defying
the laws of gravity
much appreciation to your to your to
your skillful art you know what i'm
saying or whatever went on in your life
that really helped you cultivate that
skill you know what i'm saying because
even though you know it was whooping
people's ass
i mean i have gratitude that this old
italian guy taught me this [ __ ] for free
can you imagine all that i received i
got that all this [ __ ] that's been the
other thing
i would see because this old italian guy
taught me this [ __ ] from yeah so
somebody how much gratitude i have to
have
yo somebody love you man for free yeah i
remember when i was a young kid i showed
my
my friends back in brownsville my
picture of my new family this italian
guy
and my friend told me he got killed man
like these white people love you the
[ __ ]
i wish i had some white people that
loved me yeah look at this
got that either look what somebody made
what the [ __ ] is it yo
come on look at that yo first of all
that was
like you were a superhero for people
your energy just radiated across the
world
bro is that crazy come on
yeah somebody made that get that phone
somebody created that somebody created
that on instagram dude
yeah people are doing [ __ ] of you all
the time because you
the energy that you lived with and
fought with
yeah radiated around the world man come
on that's powerful got all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm on this new
venture i know governing myself yo
that was another lifetime and then when
i look at them the more i feel like
about myself and more i realized all
this guy was created without a fear
yeah that's fascinating fear all this
fear
you know everything people love they
think that's [ __ ] that fear they
ain't no ferocious tiger that's a little
scary
mouse whoa so don't [ __ ] with the mouse
don't [ __ ] with the mouse and then in
some ways now don't [ __ ] when he's
literally he might get big
that's what i'm saying to a dragon yo
yeah
but people don't understand that and
they [ __ ] with the mice yeah don't [ __ ]
out the mouth
yeah it's true man all day
i mean that's why it's [ __ ] dude like
mike
people get big man yeah yeah they do
they get angry mm-hmm yo you still um
you still got pigeons mm-hmm what pick
up a thousand [ __ ]
what this one's a mike tyson pigeon coop
in new york or somewhere you might take
some pigeon coop in new york
on jimmy kimmel yeah me and jimmy kimmel
might take some pictures on jimmy kimmel
he came to my pigeon coop
oh ty that's good that's that
that's tight can we get this man all
right let's go over here let's go um
guys for me bird right there number
three one two
three four the four five four yeah
and that's me and my buds yeah see this
hey it's not my coop it's not cool
there's not my birds
hey let's go back to mike tyson
[Music]
yeah let's go um
that's a pigeon release no don't go that
way
hold on stop stop stop go up someone go
somewhere
more more with the
ricky flying mike tyson's pigeons or his
pigeon race to go to my pigeon racing
okay
this is tyson's corner this is something
i i absolutely
adore doing the course i'm a pigeon man
anybody that's familiar with having um
the pigeon bug knows this is going to be
amazing to all the other pigeon flight
and
my friends that see me with the birds
and um i just i wanted to do this
because this is um
this is a sport that i'm i'm deeply
involved in emotionally too
they've got some rare ones they have
these iranian rollers
you know i've been doing this since i
was nine years old you know i'm
of course people i'm more familiar with
me being a fighter but
during um the increment of my
career it's always been you see cameos
in my birthday you hear me giving
um comments about my birds and in the
interviews i wanted to show you this
[ __ ] baby you're beautiful
you don't see birds like that oh god
that was beautiful
but you still have an east coast coop
yeah yeah in new york
in new york yeah that's tight brook and
are you gonna have one here or no huh
you know i think they'd be tripping
looking all these houses my wife's gonna
get a house in um
what newport beach ain't gonna have no
goddamn
they ain't gonna have no hundreds of
pigeons flying around and [ __ ] on
everything
yeah when it houses their cars the [ __ ]
is like battery if you leave in the car
you just burn right through the car
oh oh pigeons yeah there's no one like
that you're gonna wash it
started stopping in vegas and stuff oh
really no they couldn't stop me the
whole
everybody was so pissed off the whole
block the whole you know what's that
the home union whatever they call it
yeah yeah homeowners
associations h.o.a awesome
rich and powerful and they couldn't stop
me
mr tyson no more pigeons
that's really please hate your way
yeah you're trying to get me man okay
[ __ ] hoa well what are you up to
these days brother
well um we i just got off of the
millennium tour
which was pretty much like a reunion
tour brought the group back together
you all gotta love all y'all loving oh
you love them because you gotta love
everybody got love from the group now
you love us because they're all cool
yeah i think i think that there's
always uh you know uh a aperture
of of love you know what i'm saying
because that's how we started well
if anybody i make money with really and
we partner i could never be mad with you
i can't be we have to
give another
i think that this was like a real unique
opportunity and experience because
you know we literally haven't been
together in 15 years you mean you
haven't seen each other like walking up
no we haven't all been in one place
wow for 15 years that's crazy you know
what i'm saying so this uh this tour was
you know it had its challenges you know
what i'm saying but uh
man how did the crowd feel when you come
out you still got that kind of luffy
i love it um you know shout out to all
of
the the day one fans like being able to
do this reunion tour really brought me
back to
you know how tragic it was for a lot of
our fans that we broke up
and how they really never let go of that
you know what i'm saying
so it was like a beautiful thing it was
a beautiful reunion too
that's an awesome thing you know what i
just learned from like recently that um
[ __ ] we getting ready to die it's gonna
be over let's just keep this [ __ ] loving
right yeah it's almost over yeah
yeah so it was dope man the whole
experience so
um so uh after that yeah because we just
we just
ended it on uh on on a super high note
we did uh
drake's ovo fest in toronto and we
headlined
that turkey the oh man did
what you doing tonight what's up how old
are you i still do
you know you think that sounds old when
you're young but 30 your [ __ ]
baby you think like your 20s [ __ ]
kids
[Applause]
performing every night and sell out
shows you know what i mean giving that
energy getting that
back awesomeness no feeling like that
know that somebody loves you the thing
the thought of somebody
when you guess and [ __ ] ignites you
to be
the thought of it not the actual fact
but just the thought of it oh yeah
isn't that powerful yeah
i'm so thankful for that i'm so thankful
for that like mad fans have come up to
me and just was like you know thank you
dope as hell man you know what i'm
saying icebox man that helped me get
through a breakup i'm like yo this is
why i do this
no but you know guys that you know have
been successful like especially in the
spotlight
um live was insecure so
from the beginning the reason that we
even started doing this stuff because
somebody had us on the back and said we
were good at some time
right and we always need that feeling to
the day we die for some reason
in any kind of way man good seeing you
excited again hey i remember you did
that was an incredible show you just
remember hey melanie back in the day
when such and such
is that you need that for some reason
it's just some people it's all about
that
yeah keeping it going you know
absolutely yeah
yeah it's a vibration you know what i'm
saying yeah that's what i wanted to say
it's all vibrations it's a vibration
so well i guess that's like the
fighter's thing
of you know always fighting from a place
of anger
no some people do it from a skullduggery
perspective
what am i getting out of this how am i
going to get yeah from this
yeah just look at this they look at the
fighter when he makes them that move
this could be successful
instead of me just making them make it
they're being aggressive making them
panic and make mistakes right
you know i mean some people look
somebody takes their time some fighters
are like
like floyd mayweather he takes his time
it's like painting is like painting the
[ __ ] um picture
he looks at it boom he's masterful yeah
you know it's just
like that some people do the rush kill
right
yeah right yeah that's
yeah i like that perspective yeah well
i don't i i don't know how many athletes
can come from that perspective early on
in their careers
you know depending on their teachers
yeah it all has to do with our teachers
yeah you know so as an entertainer or
performer how do you come from love
uh you know what i'm saying it has to
it has to just you know what's your
perception i love
and how does it become that perception
that you think it is i think
it's because i've always had a natural
genuine approach to things so i think
that i've always found purpose
in things because of that you know some
purpose and love
yeah because it's like okay what am i
doing this for i'm doing this for
someone or i'm doing it for myself and
someone else
yeah so i kind of have
had that perspective with all of my
experiences
the words are powerful the thought yeah
the thoughts and words are powerful
yeah definitely we are definitely what
we think we are
the illusion of ourselves
absolutely
well so what are you doing this is a
world tour of a national national tour
oh yeah well we we ended on we ended on
ovo
in toronto yeah in toronto yeah where
else did you go
man we uh we did 44 we did 44 dates
wow yeah and it i mean it was it was a
it was a it was a schedule you know we
were doing five shows a week
week after week sometimes so you know
this wasn't like
before you know when we were younger
yeah what i'm saying
yeah this was a a little bit different
but all in all man
that's a grind yeah it was a grind and
it was an amazing experience you know
something's weird isn't that
i'm telling my wife um we still feel
[ __ ] awesome upset but our bodies
getting old and it's wearing out
right you feel great don't you appear
right well see
well yeah but but but i i like i trained
i've been in the gym you know me and my
brother just rolled 38
miles on the bike oh yeah you got to do
this yeah you got to yeah
with away on you yeah so you know i'm
dancing
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah i i i
you have to
i take i if he doesn't get shot hit by
the car or get poisoned or nothing like
that
the person that lives along is the one
that has the most muscle mass
yes if it's natural living and there's
no poison no incidents it's natural i'm
living every day by day the one with the
most muscle man sleeps the longest
yeah so i i'm i'm i'm i'm
probably i take a lot of pride in taking
care of myself
so you know it's great dude it's great
yeah so after the tour um
myself and a great great friend of mine
and
just amazing you know grammy award
uh writer and entertainer james font
leroy we have a project
it's a title what song he wrote that got
the [ __ ] grammy
um it's a justin timberlake
hold on let me this is justin timberlake
song no i'm sorry bruno mars
he's a bad [ __ ] yeah yeah it's a
bruno mars song but he did
yeah he's he's written songs for justin
timberlake this guy ain't never bad on
the phone
everything he said oh yeah he wrote
beyonce
um for beyonce as well oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was a bad kid
should be the writer the writer [ __ ]
i'm the writer [ __ ]
yes so we we um we just finished up uh
a project titled passport and that's
gonna be
you know my new album that i have coming
it's it's a it's an experience
it's a visual experience so we're about
to start shooting that you need to try
some psychic ducks you ever tried some
mushrooms before
yeah oh good man i'm glad you joined
that yeah
all right he's on the plant medicine
okay
the plants is talking about but you
start seeing something laughing can't
stop laughing
that's what i love about this room oh
it's good it's just the laughter is
and i think people should laugh like
that too like yeah cause that's what
life is
it's gonna be over something you gotta
laugh you gotta have a good laugh
a little joke we're gone what the [ __ ]
is that why were we born why did we live
why are we dying
[ __ ] what's happening why
why yo you was getting lit mike you did
your one-man show too
yeah yo you guys [ __ ] keep doing mad
work i can't do it if i wasn't lit
smoke is no way i would say how the hell
can i do these shows if i'm not smoking
yeah yeah how the [ __ ] can i do this my
wife was saying just trying to i was
gonna do it i can't
i'll be too paranoid whoa in my feelings
i'll be feeling stuff to me
too close this place is too small a
couple hundred people i'll be freaking
well yeah so we're gonna we're gonna you
know
we're gonna put some new music out and
just just a lot of just creativity so
who's on your new album you got any
guests on the album no it's just
this is just pom pom pom pom
charlie james
yeah yeah i'll probably do some collabs
in the future for sure
this is like a real personal album
because this has to do with my
transformation in life you know and um
it really stemmed from just finding
self-love and i think that that is what
people need to
do more you know figure out what's
suffering no no
how do you show them the direction i
look at you talk to me self-love
my my first perspective self-love you
know when i first heard this [ __ ] right
to me why don't i love myself right i
went to i had that beautiful girl last
night that's loving myself i bought that
beautiful suit the other day
i'm driving this beautiful car i bought
this car for myself i was loving myself
i bought this house that's [ __ ] up
with the please doesn't mean you're
spoiling yourself
that's what no i don't know if that's
even spoiling myself [ __ ] yes it
is that's a form of but i think of
myself if that's what i think of loving
myself
just giving myself a bunch of [ __ ] that
i don't even need yeah nah
that's not a healthy yeah yeah that's
not even healthy
yeah that's exactly that that
perspective isn't healthy because it's
like you guys so how do you explain to
somebody
like i was how do you explain to them to
love themselves and take care of
themselves
i mean first you know i will find you
know
something that might be um
you know i would say read you know
i would say read i would offer that
supposed to go like this i never read
before i'm a [ __ ] boxer i fought for
a living
let's let's learn how to read together
let's learn how to develop that
audio book or some [ __ ] yeah let's start
with the audio books and then let's like
you know listen
somebody tell you that they're shame
that they can't read and if they're 30
years old or something
i mean i'm no therapist there's still
people that can't read
yeah you know yeah i remember i was in
the court and somebody was
he was one of the jury he was in the guy
was saying i can't read them right and
the girls and he had a million dollar
business though
wow and so she was saying how do you
handle your business he said i do the
work and my
my wife handles the numbers but the guy
couldn't read or write
huh yeah that's that's crazy and he was
pulled to be a juror
i mean he was arrested never he was
never arrested never had a problem and
stuff
he had a millionaire but he couldn't
read and write
did they did he become a juror no no
i would say i would say mike that self
love really has to do with just being
familiar with who you are
like who why why are you attached to
things you know
why do you want to do things like you
have to ask yourself
these questions and i think when you
self-realize then
we want to be accepted that's why we
have self-love okay but why do you want
to be accepted
because i want to learn who i am okay is
that the only reason
it has to be the only reason yeah but is
knowing who you
are what does that have to do with being
accepted by these guys accepting me
i'm learning through their actions and
the way they conduct themselves it's a
possibility that this could be self-love
it's not that i know it but i'm looking
for him i search for
it right and i don't know if they know
they know what self-led
love is i don't know if i can look at
somebody and say hey this guy loves
himself
he may adorn themselves with gifts his
fellow cologne has nice clothes
always have everything that's true and
he's a gentleman he doesn't have a lot
of good but he
everything looks good i might want to
conduct but that's not maybe not the
right way i don't know who knows
you got you got to find out about you
yes you've got to find out for yourself
you already do it though yeah i'm going
to talk about in general yeah yeah
how do we do it like me how do i find
out you know how many years does it take
well what would you say they die before
they figure it out what would you say
about
you yourself as far as
who am i how do i know what to do
in life to be myself or to know myself
that was my whole problem in life that's
everything i didn't know how to live
now how do you do it i do i don't go
anywhere i stay at home my family
you know i mean my perspectives are
different i don't want to [ __ ] anybody
no more i don't want to buy
a lot of fancy cars i want to buy my big
the [ __ ] well maybe we're going to do
that later but i don't want to buy the
big [ __ ] mansion right now my wife
don't want it you know
but but did that stuff bring you stress
before is that why you saying that
no but i thought that was it i just
thought this is what i don't know okay
that's how you feel everybody around me
was that way and everybody be
as a little kid that i read about was
that way right right you know me
everybody had these things and you
believe this is what you have to have to
be in this crew
right oh yeah you know yeah right
yeah yeah no i understand and it's about
paying attention to your own feelings
yeah
wow right that's tough stuff you feel
you know i don't know i know that's not
easy because that's being vulnerable to
yourself
you know yeah saying oh i don't actually
want that how come we can't help what
comes in our mind how come we can't stop
it it comes in our minds because it's
all spirit
man whoa there's a lot going on in the
head
no they're just like me it's all spirit
and we're just talking right now i'm
coming in and saying it's a [ __ ] mic
he's not cool and everything's just
going great
a lot of these things you can't control
stuff
and you know and you know this is
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] that could my
head [ __ ] it was going great right
like why am i thinking about that yeah
for sure
people look at me so mike is weird and
bugged up but yes why the [ __ ] i say
about this guy like him
you know i don't know it's just your
head looking for conflict
because people are [ __ ] people
have a very specific psychological
conscious structure that they operate
from every day
living in this world and so once you
step outside of that once you do the
toad once you get some dmt in you once
you take mushrooms
and you start to see the reality the
supreme reality that is behind
everything
[ __ ] starts to get really [ __ ] weird
man
you know i imagine a normal guy like a
normal businessman
every day he sees the same people every
day yeah the same mentality
the guy like the entertainer i gotta get
entertainer for entertaining football
players but
see all kind of weird [ __ ]
personalities don't even believe they
exist but they're existing right in
front of them
yeah said this [ __ ] for real you
know they never seen that before
you know a guy that won't shake your
hand no i don't want to do that yeah
yeah yeah
yeah how are you going to find the
contact whatever you know i don't want
to shake your hand
they never experienced anything like
that yeah yeah
no it's true man um well [ __ ] brother
it's been awesome having you guys in
here
thank you guys for having this man much
respect so what do you guys do what are
you doing like
when you leave here what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do oh
good question uh i i think we got i
think we got some [ __ ] to do
you got your workout in already uh we
gotta get that in
yeah we gotta get it listen this how it
goes let me explain something to you
right
you gotta win the day in order to win
the day you got to win in the morning
i worked out this morning though get
that workout in before your life starts
yeah then the day is already won that's
fast absolutely
he always says that yeah that's my [ __ ]
yo that's true
that's nice absolutely true absolutely
[Applause]
it's the truth i'm ready to rock come on
i'm ready world come all right come on
what you got hell yeah dude i love that
yeah no but thank you guys so much hey
t when the facility open my brother we
want to come back
oh yeah you know this is our office so
we come pull up
you guys are coming you guys are there
yeah how long do y'all gotta be in the
studio before you're going to tour
like normally fight to do six weeks oh
okay is it comparable
well no because it's like we always
as we say keep the place spinning so you
know we might be working on this project
over here
and then this one might take precedence
you know what i'm saying or you know
we're working on this
and that might happen first you know
what i'm saying so we always got some
spinning plates going so
um just yeah studios at the crib
nice yeah you know we we working you're
always in there yeah we working
what about what about trey song do you
guys ever do songs with those guys
yeah actually uh trey did a remix
on poster b yeah i mean you know i've
been do you guys get paid when they do
those rematches and stuff
well i mean it depends sometimes you
know it's some things worked out or
my friend did the stupid ass still
listen man made it the 360 deal right
no he don't know he made it up
you know it's what i'm saying why would
you want to do that [ __ ] to somebody
right yeah you know what i mean yeah
yeah why would you yeah well you go
through this because at first you know
the company said [ __ ] you said [ __ ]
them i'm going on tour [ __ ] the company
and you man you're living like a king
still you're getting all that money for
yourself now
now you can't do that now that's that's
wrong yeah yeah yeah
for sure that's big-time slave how can
you do that you can't [ __ ] do that
you can't do that you can't do that well
yeah you know it's a lot of independent
artists now you know what i'm saying
and i think that the game is completely
and because you know i'm someone that
started as young
as i did you know this is the first time
that i can say
i'm outside of the system and i own my
masters
so that's really kind of like the life
of an entertainer
and you know you have to own your math
that's not one right
that's that's so important and the
greatest artists in the world lost their
masters and some of the greatest huh
yeah it's it's your hard work it's all
your hard work you know what i mean and
it's the reverberating effect of that
like i mean i still listen to some
marvin gaye songs you know what i'm
saying
i still listen i mean this this this
music the energy that's put into music
is is magical and it's timeless you know
if
if you're a legend you know what you're
saying so you know when i was down and
down and i was also about money and i
was
[ __ ] around with drugs and i was just
a nice welcome and said i think my
children deserve to live the life that i
lived
and i just kind of like straightened up
they should be able to have their planes
and boats and do their stuff too so i
said i'm gonna train them and give them
the life that i had
you know that's not right they shouldn't
have that you know they're not their
fault that i'm an [ __ ]
right you know i [ __ ] that right right
you should live that life too
yeah yeah yeah perfectly
and they're weird i got something that's
strange he might give it all the way to
africa or haiti or somebody cause he's
one of those guys that goes to the
missionary
but that's him you know just i don't
know it's never with that guy i'm that
guy now
took me a long way to become that guy
you know at least i got there
yeah [ __ ] day
you got kids too yeah yeah yeah i got a
11 year old yeah yeah i have a ten year
that's a trip right
she a girl yes
trick yeah the little boys they're gonna
be liking her this year for sure yeah
you know i'm saying this is crazy this
is a crazy world i'm saying you could
train it with because sometimes you
think god the
coach you gotta watch the culture you
don't know
that's a trip i got some years before
that dude i got a seven
it's a beautiful thing shout out my baby
namiko i love that's what you do when
yes yes sir yes sir i should be happy
but i'm like [ __ ] off
yeah yeah i know that's gonna give me
grandkids one day i'm gonna be happy
hey hi you know all right yes right
there
yes i'm gonna be telling them stories
that my kids
don't want to hear
[Laughter]
exactly they've already heard them
yeah well where can people find you man
and check you out
yeah uh you know i highlight the boy on
uh
instagram uh omarion that's twitter as
well if you're into social media if not
you know what i mean just go to the
website
tell your girlfriends where to get in
touch with you hey i love y'all
now time is on you singing all of my
ladies all of my ladies thank you so
much for your energy y'all all came down
y'all sold out
you know um my stomping grounds in
inglewood
y'all sorted out the form two nights it
sounds like marvin gaye this one
sounds like i'm so grateful i'm i'm so
happy
you know it's gratitude i will see you
soon
love you you wanna say something bro you
know just wanna say hey
follow me on instagram papasunny uh
s-o-n-n-i-e
peace love and abundance center yourself
love yourself yiddi
love that thanks guys great show mike
abundance
abundance hey everybody that was a great
episode
absolutely loud thank you yeah a lot of
love great stuff
great wisdom shared um
check us out subscribe to our youtube
channel hot boxing with mike tyson
check out our website
hotboxingpodcast.com
until next time i'm evan britton i'm
mike tyson
boom i'm marion oh marianne
and we're out here because
[Music]
huh
[Music]
you